Я розумію що тут абсолютно всім що
я говорю і що говорять Мої колеги
даруйте на слові тому що кожен
займається в залі своїми справами Голова
Верховної Ради тре про щось кожен
Більшість депутатів сидить в мобільних
телефонах або там як як на тусовках про
на світських раутах між собою
розмовляють але ми говоримо зараз про
долі людей які мають залучати
мобілізовувати в майбутньому потенційно
овати до захисту країни і їх треба не як
в Радянському Союзі зганяти як скот а з
людьми в демократичній і вільній країні
треба поводитися відпові відповідно до
всіх світових нормальних вимог те що ми
зараз робимо буде мати дуже погані
наслідки і в тому числі і на мобілізацію
тому що системно лякати людей це
означатиме настроювати їх проти держави
а це злочин